one of your anniversary of Jerry Maguire
can you believe it this December oh it's
impossible Lance I can't be true you
complete me just shut you had me at
hello Lancer reunite plans to maybe get
together celebrate in some way I don't
know are you down oh sure
why are you hosting maybe look I mean
that movie you just clapped for it I
mean everybody loves it so much it's so
you know make it love it right what was
your favorite memory from the set what's
what's your favorite takeaway no there's
a million of them
there's a million Tom Cruise staying
until four o'clock in the morning to do
off camera across that big broom the
office space at the sports agency where
um where he knows mommy
leaving leave he stayed till 4:00 a.m.
pretty close and so do off camera and
I'm nearsighted I couldn't see him
anyway goodness it didn't matter who was
walking across the room but he was
determined to do it are you still in
touch oh yeah yeah well that makes me so
happy as a fan yeah he's a he's a really
good person yeah he's a very very good
person who's coming with me
who's coming with me I will go with you
Dorothy Boyd thank you
you